what's going on guys this is Rob and Dr
Doom becomes Thor which is amazing so
here's the thing this takes place in all
out Avengers now all out Avengers is a
five issue miniseries and it is a kind
of connected story to a degree but in a
lot of ways it's a kind of just pick
your poison type of miniseries meaning
you could read like one of the issues
you could read all of the issues it
really depends on what you like the
overall gist is still the same the only
real essential issue is issue number
five so you can read one through four or
you could read number two or number
three this one's technically number two
and then we're gonna skip all the others
because they're all basically dumb and
then we're gonna go into like number
five right the one where like Spider-Man
fights the Marvel Universe which is
pretty awesome but what this does is it
initially opens up with basically Doctor
Doom wielding Captain America's shield
and Thor's hammer literally that's how
the story opens it's kinda nuts like
it's it's pretty wild I think it's
amazing but it's pretty wild and he's
like Avengers Assemble and what they're
doing is they're fighting against a dark
Doctor Doom now it's kind of nuts here
right because as they're fighting this
guy's like yes come hurry yourselves
upon the rocks of the one true Doom it
reminds me of like the old apocalypse
quotes from X-Men the Animated Series I
am the rocks on the Eternal Shore crash
against me and be broken you know what I
mean like just the best lines ever and
like just X-Men anime series I don't
care what anybody says but it's one of
these things where you basically have
two versions of Doom now we don't
readily know exactly how this happened
but what ends up going on here is
because like Dr Doom himself really
Victor is what they call him because
Victor Iron Man She-Hulk are getting
crushed which nobody's nobody's
surprised by the fact that she-hulk's
getting wrecked but like because they're
getting absolutely crushed that like
they end up having to like flee this
battle here just kind of seems to pick
up and what is in effect a last-ditch
effort to try to like defeat this dark
version of Doom not only that what we
end up doing is seeing this they really
give it kind of getting this disembodied
voice where it says it reaches across
the Stars seeking out those who once
wronged it when it reaches Earth it will
first send the people mad we'll set them
at each other's throats Earth's hero and
protectors will fall and there will be
none to mourn their passing when the end
comes it will be Swift and it will be
brutal this I have seen this I must
prevent now one of the things to know
about all-out Avengers is that it does
segue into a story that's coming out
right now and in fact the most recent
issue just came out not too long ago
which is Avengers Beyond like literally
it came out this Wednesday and it's cool
I'm not going to tell you anything more
than that but it is very similar to the
events of Defenders Beyond if you guys
saw our coverage of the story I imagine
Marvel's doing all of this stuff because
of Avengers Secret Wars the movie that's
going to be coming out but the important
distinction here right and the important
thing is that this conversation takes
place between Victor and Iron Man as
well as Jennifer Walters and they're
seemingly the only real superheroes left
it's just like the three of them
everybody else has been taken out we
will find out what happened to them but
every everybody else has more or less
been taken out what's also crazy about
this is they talk about something called
The Soul splitter Stone like literally
Doctor Doom says our only chance is to
destroy the soul splitter Stone and
that's when Jennifer Walters chimes in
and says and watch you merge with tall
dark and dangerous and become plain old
Doctor Doom again not on your life and
of course Tony Stark chimes in and then
says dark Doom might be stronger than
all of us put together but we still have
a secret weapon that he knows nothing
about we have friendship
bruh of course he's joking here I mean
they do have the power of friendship but
what they actually have is the Book of
Wrath now here's the thing about the
Book of Wrath right the Book of Wrath is
wholly introduced here in this story
it's never been seen before and the only
real explanation that we get about this
book is that Tony Stark grabbed it
because it seemed more like an act of
desperation literally Dr Doom says the
Magics contained in this book are
unstable at Best But if I'm lucky then
there might be something in these pages
that can help us but I don't know if I
have the time so again is that's kind of
against the wall here but this is just a
magic book that may help them and that's
it but the other thing about this and
this is one of the most important things
about all-out Adventures right is that
Tony Stark says that's odd and when
Jennifer asked him what are you talking
about he says Dr Doom's experiment with
the soul splitter the power fluctuations
I detected the attack on the monastery
Dooms splitting into his light and dark
halves I know what happened but I don't
remember it now this is one of the
things that I want to specify here with
all-out Avengers right this just kind of
picks up in the middle of something this
is happening in the main Marvel Universe
this is taking place in the main Marvel
Universe but somebody is doing something
that's altering reality that's changing
existence and quite literally just
creating like these kind of alternate
timelines that exist out there and
sending the Avengers spinning through
them it's why each one of these stories
are kind of self-contained that yes it
features The Avengers but it's different
Avengers rosters who are doing different
things and reality is just kind of being
twisted and distorted in different ways
whoever's doing this is one of the most
powerful characters in existence hint
hint nudge nudge wink wink so the thing
about this is that what they end up
doing is literally contacting blade and
the reason why is because in addition to
everything going on with dark Doom
there's all these like demons and stuff
that are kind of being summoned around
the world vampires and so on and so
forth and of course blade is basically
crushing them which by the way I don't
know if you guys are reading it but
there's a mini series called bloodline
it's not done yet but it's about the
daughter of Blade it's amazing I don't
know if anybody's reading that right now
but it's phenomenal and I'm excited to
check it out once it's finished it
finishes in June so like I'm really
hyped to see how this thing ends It's
pretty dope so jumping back to like dark
Doom what we end up finding is that this
guy is captured Captain America he's
captured Thor and he's captured Carol
Danvers now here's the kicker about all
this right we don't get a whole lot of
information about dark Doom but what
seems to be going on here is that of
course Dr Doom and Victor are two sides
of the same coin that because of the
Soul splitter Stone the nature of Doctor
Doom himself as a singular character was
split in half his evil half and what you
could what passes for his good half I
don't know if Doctor Doom really has a
good half we literally just covered a
story where he encountered an alternate
reality version of himself who like made
the world and even the universe like
this Utopia and Doctor Doom wiped out
the whole universe because he considered
that version of himself to just be
lesser right because his Dark Helmet
said good is dumb like that's literally
it so I mean I don't know if Doom has a
good side that was the Doctor Doom solo
series by the way you'll find a link to
it down in the description you can check
it out once you're done with this video
it's it's great but of course one of the
things that happens is that like he sort
of calls out Captain America right
because this version of dark Doom seems
to have none of the restrictions that
Victor Von Doom normally has right this
is just unbridled power and and just
like desire that's really all it is and
so Captain America kind of chimes in
with like his normal Captain America
stuff you know like oh you think you're
gonna win you think you've already won
and the response of Doom is is this the
part where you tell me that it's all
still for play this is never going to
succeed Captain America is like no this
is the time that I tell you that like my
friends are coming and they do right
here's the funny thing about this Iron
Man's flying in right and so literally
like dark Doom realizes that that Iron
Man's coming and he uses his power to
like shut down his suit right and he
just crashes into the ground and Iron
Man's out of commission now that's it
and then Jennifer Walters jumps in right
like She-Hulk jumps in and tries to
attack this guy right it's like look at
her right isn't she magnificent right a
strength rising to match that of the
Hulk himself but applied judiciously
strategically some foes need brute force
to be overcome some need intelligence
She-Hulk has it all She-Hulk will
single-handedly win and then it's like
nope because dark Doom literally just
crushes her which is not surprising at
all but then at that point like this is
when Victor Von Doom shows up and like
Victor attacks dark doom and then in the
middle of all this he starts brandishing
like the Book of Wrath and that's when
this version of himself starts to kind
of panic right he was like no you can't
like you cannot use this thing it'll
ultimately lead to my destruction and
it's kind of funny because at the end of
the day it all turns out to be a ruse
right he's like oh no please not that
you know not the Book of Wrath
like literally starts laughing at him
and he's just like like how quickly
you've become one of them Victor to
believe that some stupid Book of Wrath
would be able to defeat me you think
that's how I'm going to lose you think
that's how dark Doom is going to die by
like a magic book that's not going to
happen but the reality here is that all
of it was a ruse the whole thing was a
trick and the reason why is because
blade is a character that just no one
really seems to pay attention to
including dark Doom him self blade quite
literally snuck in and then got his
hands on the soul splitter Stone and
then threw it to Doctor Doom and as soon
as Victor Von Doom gets it he crushes it
and that leads to the reunification of
himself and his dark Doom right so
literally a reunified version of Victor
Von Doom and so once he's here like once
he's back to himself the threat's
basically quelled and then he tells Tony
Stark the reward for you guys helping me
restore myself is you get to leave with
your life which is the closest you're
going to get to a thank you from Doctor
Doom those are guys who are familiar
with Doctor Doom and I don't know
anybody who isn't familiar with Dr Doom
but in case you're not familiar with him
he doesn't say thank you you don't get a
thank you from Victor Von Doom you get
to continue living right like that's
that's your thanks you're the things you
get is you get to just keep on living
your life and that's it I gotta be
honest man Dr Doom's just one of the
best villains ever in the entirety of
comics but the funny thing about this is
that what ends up happening is when they
get back to their base and seemingly
everything kind of gets uh you know goes
back to normal that Iron Man is like
download the last 48 hours worth of
footage and the response of his system
is file not found and it's like footage
corrupted and he's like wait a minute
everything that happened in the last 48
hours is gone and it's like the footage
is corrupted so basically everything's
kind of been switched back to normal but
when that happened everything that
documents what's happened has
effectively vanished here it's gone so
again whoever is manipulating things
behind the scenes is one a high-level
reality warper and two somebody who's
able to corrupt the footage of Iron Man
which is not a very impressive feat for
a person who can alter reality like I
have the power to alter reality on a
universal scale and I will use my Powers
by giving you a computer virus like it's
just kind of weird it's kind of strange
but with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end thank
you all for watching and I will catch
you all later
peace